こんな肇社長です皆さん乗り物なに乗ってますか
すごい抽象的ですみません結婚世の中乗り物多いところですよ
一般的には自動車電車とか色々あるんですけどもまぁそれ以外にも乗り物鉄道は色々
ありまして例えばですけどもた9魔とか
スケボーとかキックボードとかねキックボートとか
ティックボードとなるんですけど嘘キックボード
キックもと取ったことありますかなんか僕小学生の時はもう自転車乗ってる奴だがた生
みたいな風潮があって男は黙ってキックボードっていう時代があったんですよしって
レベルかわかんないんですけどもこうやってなって地面をキックすると前に進むって
いうやつなんだけどもそのなんか自転車とかす希望とかキックボードにそうして言える
ことは全部ですねらこっちからを入れなきゃいけない
スケボーとかたとこがなきゃいけないして自転車もこうやってなんかこういう動きが
起きるキックローダを地面を蹴らなきゃいけないって
動きがあるのに戻って基本的になる凍っ大変なんですよですがレースが今日ですね何度
スポーツ用品店に行ったらたまたま多分これ一番力が必要ないんじゃないかっていう
乗り物見つけてしました
こちらですスペース
ケーター the new y チョウラィず x560
ジャストぱんぱん土工って書いたんですけどもまぁやってる分かると思います
1回開けてみましょう値段が一番3000でちょっと高い高いがマジでスゴいと思うん
でさぁ日さに外で撮ってるんでちょっと緊張してます
ん
いい
入ってるのはこんくらいでしためんどくせーけど作っちゃうよ
ん
th
明日釣ったよたぶん高校のような音が出るんですけどこれこれがこれが多分的になると
思う
これ待ってこれ終わったからまあでもこれがあったができるお店
生きた池田を応援歌でも某だぞ多分
くそういるぞん
すごい面倒くせえねこれ取れたら多分もう終わりですねさてはこれやばい活性やば移動
よくすればいいんだ
うそあとここだけです多分
[音楽]
なぜか交互これまで通りえええ
はいする会社3月だってこれでちょっと小さいであろうと思いますや公園にいてもね
なんとかなるほど効く
ためですねこれこれでなんとか切り下げますよやっぱね家のものに頼っていてもダメな
んですよ
こういう野外でも俺ができるところを見せたいあらーなるか腹 h パブロれ
そこには
公園で一人座り込む
26歳の
姿があったのです
ん
頬をパパっはぁっ
じゃあみんなちゃんと思っておりますここまできたらもう余裕して食べの後はこの
タイヤつけるだけですこうやって親ホイホイ
を出来た出来た人できた余った野菜みんなもうちょっとした俺が死んじゃうくらい高く
しなきゃいけないんでここはなレア度はハンドルをつけるだけです多分 a もう完成
ぱーせぷからなんか不安などは何なんだろう俺もやばいはここで一近くデフレってかね
よし
ていた
たぶんできました完成ですこちらが近未来の乗り物ですあっはい付で
御影方がキック bot とか全然違うずをキックロードっていうのは超えて乗って
蹴って進むやつなんですよ
ページがこれは違いますけれんじゃなくて
高校わかりましたありますかね
このこのこれですよ
これこれはかですこんなこれこれではこれこれこれこれプロ設ける必要もないんですよ
ね
めっちゃ楽じゃないこれあれの次世代できるようなん
いや水泳楽なんですよこれラックすぎて心配になるくらいでございます
いうのがあるんですよすごくないですかこれどういうシステムがわかんないんですけど
こぐとこうやって前に進むポストって前に進むみたいな感じらしい
音ですねあっはぁっ
入ってくれ俺が
リーダードライビング的に好きっ
ん
me
[音楽]
ん
ちゃんと買った
昨今えっはいというわけでみんな見てもらった通りこれマジで楽だし早いんですよ
この公演からの誤検知まで5キロぐらいあるんですけども車だと16分かかるらしいで
どこだと5時間かかるらしいねこれぐらいの速さの落差だったらたく16分もかかん
ないぐらいも多分
日が暮れる前までに家までつけると思うんでちょっとどんな得てか
れるか測ってみると思いますたぶん車より早いと思います何から事業者より楽です的で
5キロオーナー面で帰れるかやってみましょう
ゴールで待ってるけどいます良い
ドン
持っていた
ユラを
[音楽]
me
ですが web タイムが
28分22秒
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ